une tragédie un drame qui reste sept ans
plus tard toujours sans coupable
rappelons d'abord les faits nous sommes
le 2 mai 2014 ukraine est alors en plein
trouble déchiré entre partisans de
l'intégration à l'union européenne
à l'ouest et ceux fidèles à l'amitié
avec la russie voisine à l'est sur la
place maïdan les protestataires pro
européens parviennent à faire chuter le
gouvernement
dans ce qui est présenté comme la
révolution orange par ses partisans et
plus prosaïquement comme un coup d'état
par ses opposants
une opposition qui déborde vite le cadre
de manifestations pacifiques
les violences se multiplient notamment
perpétré par les milices néonazis de
private sector côté pro européen à
odessa ville du sud de l'ukraine
les affrontements sont récurrents tout
débute par une rencontre de football
de nombreux hooligans ont infiltré les
rangs des supporters en marge de la
rencontre ils sont allés directement sur
l'esplanade où étaient rassemblés les
antilles meydan devant la maison des
syndicats
très rapidement le campement est attaqué
il est temps de brûler devant cette
violence ray centaine de militants se
réfugie dans la maison des syndicats
mais les forces d'extrême droite
fasciste d'essayer de mettre le feu au
bâtiment et empêchent les gens de sortir
ce qui arrive à s'enfuir sont attaqués
les images sont terribles et le bilan
est lourd 42 militants pro russes
meurent asphyxiés par de l'oxydé de
carbone ou en sautant du bâtiment en
flammes
quelques heures avant ce drame six
autres personnes avaient été tuées dans
des affrontements un souvenir douloureux
pour la plupart des habitants d'odessa
les victimes elles n'ont toujours pas
obtenu justice la sphère est très peu
médiatisé et aujourd'hui encore aucun
coupable n'a été désigné un seul
responsable de cette inaction quand
l'eau est nu les nouvelles autorités
ukrainiennes parvenu au pouvoir après le
renversement du gouvernement
certaines procédures pénales ouvertes
après ces faits tragiques sont restés à
l'étape de l' enquête préliminaire alors
que d'autres en sont en procès
judiciaire ce qui laisse à penser que le
pouvoir n'était pas réellement
intéressés à ce que justice soit faite
pour les victimes tandis que les
coupables ne sont pas poursuivis
pour certains experts que l'anc est en
soi au point mort malgré les preuves
évidentes de la responsabilité dans
cette attaque ce n'est pas une surprise
edmond rien de seine éditeurs et
spécialiste de la région parlait déjà il
ya deux ans à notre micro de ce qu'il
qualifie d' obscénité l'occident dans
cette affaire c'est facile de faire
obstruction sur une rue le jeu sur une
affaire qui dérange donc il n'y a pas eu
là il n'y a pas eu la preuve c'est
qu'ils ont ils avaient si vous voulez
les photos de tous les agresseurs puis
les vidéos ça aurait été très facile de
retrouver les agresseurs il n'y a eu
aucune aucune inculpation au culot ils
n'ont jamais été inquiétés si vous
voulez ces gens là c'est vrai que c'est
ce qui a chez certains à déclencher
effectivement une volonté
d'effectivement de s'engager pour que
j'ai six soirs en vue et que la justice
soit rendue de manière impartiale
elle ne peut l'être impartial que par
des communes instances internationales
comme l'onu
à condition qu'elle ne soit pas bloquée
dans ses décisions par deux ou trois
leaders dont la france qui obstruent une
déclaration toujours valable aujourd'hui
l'anc est au point mort d'une certaine
manière ne fait qu'accentuer les
tensions entre la russie et l'ukraine
malgré l insistance des familles des
victimes pour que la communauté
internationale agisse
à défaut elles viennent honorer leur
mémoire chaque de mai en se recueillant
devant la maison des syndicats
mais leur amertume et leur chagrin
grandit d'année en année